I'm joined today by mark Ruskin who's an
FBI was an FBI special special agent for
27 years working undercover for which he
was awarded five commendations he's also
an attorney worked as an assistant
district attorney in Brooklyn New York
worked for US Senator Daniel Moynihan
and his great new book is the Pretender
my life undercover for the FBI mark it's
so great to talk to you I'd like to
start a little bit with your background
so you're from a secular Jewish family
I'm from a secular Jewish family I can
tell you if I had told my secular Jewish
family I was joining the FBI I don't
think it would have been particularly
thrilling for them I mean what was that
like within your family well I have to
say that the reaction was not exactly an
outpouring of joy from my parents you're
my father was a physician who's not
deceased and his father was a physician
and in the family the tradition was to
go into medicine I did second best which
was to go into law school for those who
couldn't quite cut it to become a doctor
and the pattern my parents envisioned
for me of course was to you know start
you know work maybe in public service as
a prosecutor or defense lawyer for a few
years then go to work for a law firm and
have a nice quiet safe job in a in a
prestigious law firm so when I deviated
deviated is almost a to milder term when
I took that out the window basically in
order to join the FBI which was a
nassima as you know to any Jews
especially secular Jews in the 50s and
60s the it wasn't particularly well
received ultimately though they came
around and came to respect my choice and
what I was doing you know to protect
America and also to protect civil rights
which was one of the big concerns what
is the precursor to sort of like
full-blown undercover work I interviewed
and I know you know him Chris vos a
couple of months ago he was at one point
you know big time negotiator within the
FBI and he talked about he
was working at a suicide hotline
part-time while a special agent and
eventually was able to use that to
transition into negotiations what sort
of the precursor for undercover work
well first I mentioned with regard to
Chris as you recall from the book when I
went to us and Shawn in Paraguay to
rescue the former Miss Paraguay who had
been kidnapped
Chris Voss the expert on kidnapping was
my lifeline from Quantico who provided
invaluable advice when we ultimately did
save her in terms of the Precourt kirsta
to doing undercover work one of the
things which was very helpful to me is
when I was an assistant district
attorney in Brooklyn prior to becoming
an FBI agent I worked in their
investigations Bureau for about a year
and conducted literally hundreds of
interrogations of and people who had
committed murders all kinds of heinous
crimes and I became I think developed an
expertise in learning when I'm being
lied to and being able to detect the
subtle signs of being lied to and also
in developing rapport we trying to get
people who had committed these terrible
crimes to tell me about their crimes
essentially tell me things which were
against their interest I had to learn
how to push the right buttons and
quickly develop a rapport and these are
skills which were invaluable to me as an
undercover agent you know learning to
push the right button to get people to
trust me and to confide in me was really
key to being able to be successful as a
UC as well as being able to tell when
people are lying to me
because a good criminal which is were
always pretending to be has to have a
sense of when he or she is being lied to
talk a little bit about the sort of
creation of the identities that you
assume there's a term called
backstopping which you talk about in the
book it would be great if you could tell
us a little bit of what backstopping is
what goes into it but also how many
people within the FBI are aware of any
particular identity that you are
assuming for an operation
generally speaking the only people who
be aware of my fictitious identity and
we call it a fit which is the alias and
false ID so the acronym is a fit the
only people who could be aware of my a
fit would be the UC team the team that
was supporting me that normally there'll
be a case agent sometimes two case
agents a financial analyst some other
agents occasionally lending support in
their surveillance capacity but other
than this intimate small group no one
else would know about the the false ID
the concept of backstopping is very
different in real life than what one
imagines when one sees in the films and
on television on the on the TV screen
the supervisor hands undercover agent
the wallet and says okay mark here's
your new ID you're now David Pakman and
your birthday is such and such and so
memorize all the details and go out and
do it and we in real life is just the
opposite
creating a fictitious ID is a
painstaking job often taking as much as
six months because one has to create an
ID which is verifiable so everything
that you are going to be telling people
or writing down has to be something that
if someone looks to check it out that
they can confirm that it really happened
so in one of my cases one of my first
deep cover cases which was comic or an
investigation into corruption and fraud
on Wall Street I had to develop an ID
which had me as having lived in Puerto
Rico for many years I'm an ADA of
Argentina as you mentioned I speak
Spanish fluently so we worked and I've
lived in Puerto Rico and worked there so
we worked that into my background and
what I had to do was I went to actually
went travels to Puerto Rico and met with
individuals who would later be able to
verify that I was their tenant so for
example someone who owns several
condominiums agreed to be my
quote-unquote landlord and we actually
looked at apartments
he had the dates he created a fictitious
file that he could refer to so later on
he could say that
and the name I was using was an H mark
barnard the H mark Renaud yes he was my
canon he lived in one of my apartments
from this year to that year and so forth
and I also met with a small businessman
who agreed to vouch as my employer so
that I could list him as a prior
employment and how do you tell them mark
about what you're doing in other words
do you tell them just the bare minimum
do they understand that this is an
identity that's required for an FBI
operation yeah these are usually
individuals which we refer to as friends
of the bureau either civilians who are
sympathetic to the mission of the bureau
to fighting organized crime to fighting
fraud and fighting terrorism and are
willing to pitch in to lend a hand in
order to make our endeavors successful
and without the friends of the bureau it
would be a tough job indeed or they
would know is it it's an undercover case
you know we would approach them some of
these individuals are approached by me
personally others by intermediaries and
all that they would be told is mark they
may not even know my true name that we
have an undercover
he needs a fictitious landlord or
employer can you help us out and that
would be it that would be all they would
know because the less they know the less
that they can inadvertently leaked out
and then potentially damage the
operation so continuing down the line
you get the fictitious ID developed and
backstopped how do you develop the look
for an undercover identity and in the
book you talk about you know playing a
quote Hispanic guy French as well you
were born in France for people who don't
know Italian in other operations how do
you start to develop the physical
appearance well in the preparation for
the case I mean as I mentioned the
backstopping would take about six months
and the other phases which were going on
simultaneously
the case agent would be drafting an
undercover proposal that's a
a book sized document that had to be
approved at FBI headquarters but while
all that's going on I'm essentially
studying the crime problem and studying
the individuals learning as much as I
can about them the ones who are going to
be the targets of the investigation and
based on what I learn about them I try
to develop a persona that is going to be
someone they can relate to so if it's a
case like run DMV which was the case
it's long term two-and-a-half year
undercover group one we call the Group
one which is a major undercover
operation lasted two and a half years I
knew it was gonna be street-level type
people it would be the intermediary to
obtain fraudulent documentation for
terrorists mafiosos fugitives or people
who also sell drugs they also sell guns
stolen cars it's it's essentially almost
we considered organized street crime it
was a level above the street criminal so
I had to develop a persona that they
could relate to in that case there was
Alex Perez a fugitive from Miami Florida
so I grew a ponytail at that ponytail
halfway down my back you will be able to
tell from my hair today but in those
days I could do that and I wore three or
four gold chains around my neck three
four gold chains around my wrist
courtesy of the FBI's seized property
unit you know these were change which
had been seized from drug dealers and so
forth my car has a late-model Mercedes
or other high-end card had Miami Metro
Dade license plates which it knows in
Miami in that the time was I was the
capital of cocaine and my car
even though had Florida plates had never
been south of Brooklyn but I would show
up and for me it's in this case and the
car with the Florida plates would
announce that this was some guy you know
from the cocaine capital and I get out
of the car with my ponytail with my
bling
I'm gelling that my hair my shirt
unbuttoned Lily down to my navel and
that would send signals to the subject
so that even before I opened my mouth
they were already 90% convinced that I
was some kind of shady character that
they could trust basically how much
contact do you have with your family and
friends during deep cover work I
recently in addition to reading your
book to prepare for our interview I read
Donnie Brasco by Joseph Gaston and you
know he had incredibly limited contact
with his family during his six years
operation what what about you well Joe
Pistone I read Donnie Brasco the way
other people would read a textbook in in
professional school when I was starting
to do you see work there was no training
there was no school and the only way to
learn basically other than doing it was
to read the memoirs of other agents and
that and his was one of the major books
I read I mean reading Donnie Brasco for
me was it was a big learning experience
and assisted me greatly in terms of
learning how to be a you see the the and
I'll also mention that that Joe Pistone
did a blurb for the for my book which is
and and I had the opportunity to work
with him a couple of times over the
years but as far as seeing family is
concerned there are different degrees
and this doesn't come across in the
movies too much there are different
degrees of deep cover
so my first case calm car I referred to
earlier the white collar case was a
really deep deep cover I mean I was
doing that one 24 hours a day seven days
a week I had an apartment I lived in I
had a car with a garage I had my job as
a crooked broker that I went through
every day and in that case I did have
very limited contact with my family and
that was a strand man with friends and
that was a great strain but other cases
which I deep
don't involve necessarily seven days a
week in in run DMV I would generally go
home at night but what I would do before
got my own real home not some fictitious
on the cover home but what I would do is
I would dryclean on the way home and the
dry cleaning is a tradecraft term which
involves taking making taking certain
measures to make sure you're not being
followed so I get into my undercover car
get on the highway drive a bit and a
regular speed limit speed then let's say
slow down to 30 miles per hour in the
right lane and see if anybody else is
slowing down or I would get off at an
exit but then I get off at an exit I go
down thirty yards and pull off to the
shoulder see who else is getting off at
that exit wait five minutes put my car
into reverse and back up get back on the
highway and drive on anybody who's been
following me now has lost me also going
through stop signs making u-turns
illegal u-turns little things like that
once I become stable knowing that there
was no one on my tail then I could go
home so in cases like that I was still
able to maintain a relationship with
family and friends and even though they
were Deep Cover operations as far as
concealing my residents from their
subjects that's normal more when I'm
acting like a criminal which I have to
do to be persuasive to have to gain the
conscience of criminals I have to act
the way they do they're not advertising
to me where they live
sure me they don't want me to know where
they live because if I get busted
I can call if I have a real criminal I'm
more than likely than not to call them
up there ya go okay you look you give me
a break and I'll tell you where this guy
lives and he's what he's involved in so
it's very natural for criminals to
conceal a lot of personal data from each
other and for me to conceal my residents
facts about my personal life from other
criminals it all it did was enhance my
credibility certainly didn't make him
suspicious in the least we're speaking
with former FBI Special Agent Mark
Ruskin the book is the Pretender my life
undercover for the FBI
we will pause and continue with mark on
tomorrow's program we're continuing our
conversation with mark Ruskin he's a
former FBI special agent for 27 years
worked undercover in a number of
different operations his book is the
Pretender my life undercover for the FBI
so picking up sort of where we left off
I'd love to dig into in the book you
mentioned and you sort of mentioned it
in the first part of the interview good
versus bad questions when you are
wearing a wire as it's called and trying
to elicit incriminating statements from
subjects can you give us some examples
of good and bad questions or way to
handle conversations well I'll tell you
about what the what bad questions are
like bad questions are the ones that the
prosecutors the US Attorney's ask you to
ask at the next meeting you know we have
meetings with the case agent and the
prosecutor and the prosecutor say to me
mark look next time you meet with Jose
ask him where he got the gun so I ask
him where he got the cocaine and
basically the bad questions are the
questions that make you look like a cop
you're a real criminal and to be a
successful you see you have to be able
to think and behave like a real criminal
a real criminal has three things in his
mind or her mind basically one is to
make money one is to not get arrested or
to lose not to get arrested and threes
to not get hurt or injure not to get
injured so if I'm acting with these
three principles in mind I'm meeting
with some other bad guy I'm thinking I
want to get arrested I'm not gonna ask
him questions or or I expect him to ask
me questions which are going to give up
information about myself which would
that would hang him up I'm not gonna ask
him things that I don't need to know but
where did you find cocaine why do I need
to know where he got the cocaine there
all I'm gonna care about is that the
cocaine is good quality and I'm getting
a good price for it and I'm gonna make a
lot of money selling it anything else
that I ask about is gonna set off alarm
bells in the back of the guy's mind what
I have to do if I want that kind of
if I have to develop enough to rapport
so that eventually the subject is going
to volunteer the information we do small
talk we chat will have a bite to eat
maybe have to buy or something like that
and then slowly elicit the information
but in such a way that it doesn't look
like I'm asking so in such a way that
maybe flatter the person like hey this
is really great cocaine I've never seen
such pure stuff and then the guys will
and you know feels flattered right so
he's got the are well you know I was
able to bring it in from Malaysia or
whatever and so it's a volunteer because
he's bragging about the information but
that's how you do it you have to be very
subtle if you look like you've been
nosey and asking for things you don't
need to know you're just gonna either
get the door shut in your face or god
forbid worse into the next meeting and
mark when it got some of these meetings
and byes I mean you described in the
book one situation where someone you
were with sort of froze and and said you
were Colombian right and that wasn't
part of the backstory that you had
agreed upon how do the sort of different
you know you talked about Argentina
Puerto Rico and Colombia three very
different versions of Spanish or spit or
accents that are spoken in those three
places how did you manage that and
wasn't there a risk of someone sort of
being a little bit curious as to why
your accent didn't match the place you
were supposedly from well I was very
careful in terms of using a judgement in
terms in terms of telling people where I
was from bet based on their own personal
ethnicity so in the run-in V case I was
dealing with a lot of Dominicans and
Puerto Ricans and with them I told them
I was a Cuban from Miami because they
would know Cuban accent from Venezuelan
accent from any other actions and it was
it worked fine when I was dealing with
real Cubans I would of course never tell
them I was Cuban because they were in a
heartbeat know that I was in enact cases
I would just say I was from Buenos Aires
I was margin Tina but I wanted it to fit
to fit the story and I'll tell you one
amusing note was with a coyote a fellow
who used to smuggle people across the
border and in New York he specialized in
immigration documents and he's one of
the characters in in the book and I was
having a meet with him downtown in
Manhattan once I was I was posing as a
Columbian fugitive who was trying to you
know who's illegally in the United
States and I needed to get a green card
and for $15,000 he was obtaining a green
card for me and it involved various
visits to immigration downtown and one
meeting across from the federal building
he gets into my undercover car which was
a red Jeep Cherokee at the time and he
says to me you know in Spanish we're
talking Spanish and he goes you know
poor guy from Venezuela from Colombia
rather why is it that you speak with a
French accent and he picked up he was
the first one in years we never picked
up on the accent because I've seen Simon
native French speakers you pointed out
my accent in Spanish is bit French my
ores are French and I was like taking
her back and I had a leat Alice my
undercover girlfriend in the back and
she kind of froze and then I thought to
myself well the sometimes the big lie is
the lie that works the best well so I
tell him listen you know don't I don't
tell people about this but when I was 18
I got into big jam in Colombia and it
was the kind of thing that could easily
have gotten me killed and there was no
one I could go to because they're all
the bad people the different gangs were
after me the police who asked me so what
I did is I went to Europe I escaped to
Europe and joined the French Foreign
Legion right now that seems like totally
ridiculous - incredible story and that's
it and as I said after ten years you
know the accent just rubbed off on me
and then we had a meeting he got the
other car and I'm after them driving off
with with
Alice and I'm saying gee I wonder if
he's ever gonna meet with us again that
was the most preposterous thing I've
ever said two weeks later we have
another meeting he jumps back into my
car everything is fine and he says to me
he goes yeah you know I saw I saw some
of your friends on TV the other day
hey so some of my friends I have no idea
what the hell he's talking about some of
my friends on TV they're really who's
that he goes open Desert Storm over in
Iraq they had their show on the news a
bunch of French Foreign Legion soldiers
getting off a plane oh okay that's it
well yeah right a lot of my buddies are
in Iraq now boy am I glad I'm not with
them now I wouldn't want to be in that
hellhole that's for sure and we were
fine we were friends it's a work you
showed me that sometimes the bigger the
whopper you know the bigger the lie the
more likely it is to be swallowed and
speaking of the French stuff there was a
moment where you were sort of looking
for angling for a position in Paris and
someone in the FBI who also wanted that
position sort of cast doubt as to your
loyalty to the United States based on
your French background and desire to
maybe one day retire in Paris now you
were ultimately sort of cleared I guess
the term would be but are those types of
loyalty doubts ever 100% resolved in the
FBI or once you're sort of tagged with
that it can only ever be 99% resolved in
my case I don't think it was ever really
100% resolved in that the Security
Division had obtained had reached such a
level of power what happened was after
the Hanson case now this was the case
were Robin Hanson was uncovered he was a
mid-level FBI management official who
was found to have been a Russian spy
right and actually Eric O'Neill the FBI
agent who was brought in to sort of
prove the case we interviewed him years
ago and he was played by Ryan Philippi
in the movie on the subject and it was a
very good movie but he did a lot of
damage but some of the collateral damage
he did is that he created
you know he was he was the origin of
what became an environment of some
paranoia in the bureau the Security
Division which has always been in the
past
kinda like a backwater division that you
know only I want to disparage them but
but the first-class agents let's say
would not be seen working in all of a
sudden now they attained a power that
they never had before because everyone
was worried that they were spies all
over the place and so you had these
these age and some of whom had very
little field experience making these
important decisions about people's
careers and when I had applied for the
Paris post as you mentioned that and I
was actually awarded the Paris post I
was assigned to be working at the
Embassy
the US Embassy in Paris because of this
anonymous letter and it turned out I
find out who wrote it twitting my
loyalty isn't the question for several
months the position was held up and
ultimately I was not sent to Paris now
it's basically told to go on to Paris I
was offered the position of one of Cyrus
and they said look you can take this or
leave it but this is all this is a all
the best you're gonna get which was
pretty good so I I was happy to get that
but the the shadow I think persisted
until until I retired especially since
they found out at that point I don't
think they realized I was the dual
national but once the Security Division
found out that I actually had both
French and US nationality then then they
really got the bug up there you know
work last thing I want to touch on mark
in the limited time we have left so you
are retired now
how much do you worry about people
looking for you coming after you people
from operations people that maybe did
time in prison but have gotten out or
scheduled to get out how much do you
worry about that I think for the most
part a lot of them were professionals
and foes you know they and I got the
impression after the
asked that the attitude was you know we
would do our job you were doing your job
you know nothing personal some of the
others even if they may not look at it
from such a aloof point of view at least
they realized that were they to take
some action against an FBI agent that it
was essentially be like the sky falling
on their heads the they would have the
weight of the entire FBI on top of them
because the FBI protects its own so
today now most of these people get a
middle-aged or older you know are they
really gonna want to invite a life of
hiding essentially for the rest of their
lives to have their so that's that goes
into the calculation as well and the
ones who are really wacky or crazy and
then I'm sure you remember Polly guess
who talking about on the board if you're
not using that true names in the in the
book and kind of disguising the fact a
little bit so that they were not in
readily identifiable yeah
and for the most part they're not the
kind of people who browse at Barnes and
Nobles you know looking at you know in
the in the illiterate nonfiction section
I gotcha
I will tell you once again the book is
the Pretender my life undercover for the
FBI I highly recommend the book and
we've been speaking with the books
author mark Ruskin today mark really a
pleasure speaking to you and I
appreciate your time David thank you
very much for inviting me